now why am I so proud to be here in
Florida well because freedom is here to
stay
[Applause]
freedom for people across this country
and indeed across the world
we faced attacks we took the hits
we weathered the storms
but we stood our ground we did not back
down we had the conviction to guide us
and we had the courage to lead we made
promise his
we made promises to the people of
Florida and we have delivered on those
promises
and so today after four years the people
have delivered their verdict freedom is
here to stay
chills up my spine man because that's
what it's all about that's what it's all
about and you know you don't become a
leader overnight it takes a long time to
do it and Ron desantis's life has led
him to this you know I was checking this
morning you know that Rhonda Sanders is
44 years old he's two years younger than
me that bizarre like the guy is in his
prime and he is ready to fight and Lead
he really is ready and how did he do it
well he he was competent he was clear he
fought the bureaucrats and then when the
culture of war came here he fought back
he didn't get into the culture War for
the hell of it but when it came here and
schools were teaching young boys that
they're actually young girls and
teachers were talking about to kids
about sexuality privately and hiding it
from the parents and then when that was
rocket fueled by Disney which is one of
the biggest corporations in the world
which is HQ right here in Orlando
Florida what did he do he fought them he
fought the woke and well he brought
brought that up in his speech as well
[Applause]
Embrace freedom
s payers and we reject woke ideology
we fight the Wok in the
immature we've
we've been the schools we fight the woke
and the corporations we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob Florida is
where woke goes to die
I mean Florida is where we'll go through
that I like powerful stuff I I think
that was the best speech of his life so
far I think his energy was just right
obviously the energy in the room was
electric uh nobody nobody even though I
crazily said to him he was going to win
by 15 points nobody expected the
20-point win but he stepped up there and
just knocked it out of the park as a
former baseball player would do